your friend ashton kutcher became
literally my marker to all my friends i
was like if any of you ever put me on
that show punk i will never speak to you
again
because it is it's like i you know what
i hate in life as much as i'm like a
scrappy cat i do not like gotcha moments
don't let me work my entire life to be a
good person and then nail me in a corner
poking me like an animal and then going
oh that's who she really is we knew we
knew it that it's fake she's not a good
person she's a jerk but i do love ashton
kutcher nothing against him but boy that
show really scared me well then you're
gonna hate this ashton come on out
okay there is a
that 90s show revival there is yeah
it's starring
uh deborah joe rupp who played my mom
and kerwood smith and they're great
friends of mine and amazing people and
and a whole new group of kids yeah
yeah okay tell me about the show that
you are now second season big hit really
respected great reviews thank you home
economics i love it it's like
this cast is
yeah i really feel like i was part of a
dream team before and i was
so nervous because because of kovid i
met all of them but i hadn't been in the
same room with all of us together
it's like dating or something at first
you go
you just you can't predict it you don't
know until you show up and the first day
i went to work i was so nervous
and then about two days in i was driving
home and i was like just straight up
cocky it's like they're so great i was
like i don't even have to do anything
they're just my favorite group of people
well there is another television show
that i heard you are a fan of
okay yeah i mean yeah look i'm into the
bachelor okay yeah i i i wasn't
originally i started dating a girl uh
she became my wife
and she like pushed it on me and then
like a couple years into it i started to
realize like when i was out of town i
was like well you're not you're not
going to watch it tonight right can you
like wait until
which by the way i missed uh women tell
off okay what are you thinking
prediction wise that's going to happen
like for because we're almost at the end
of the season i know i without watching
women tell all i'm hesitant to make any
firm predictions well there is someone
um actually here that we have as a
surprise for you who i think can fill in
some blanks who oh it's just the host of
the show jesse palmer
you just i know i'm not ashton kutcher
she just said she hates gotcha moments
she sets you up for a while squeeze on
it we're not going to tease you
that's why when like oh this is an
amazing surprise is it better it's great
i know i was listen just like your
childhood i was like drinking in a
parking garage down the street here in
new york and i heard that you were this
big fan of the show so on behalf of
bachelor nation i just wanted to stop by
and say thank you man i appreciate it
you gotta do me a favor
you gotta look into the camera and say
hello to my wife i'll get so many
brownie points say hello ashley grace
uh
she's so jealous right now go ahead
ashley grace will you accept topher's
final rose
[Applause]
i also want to say hi to my friend wendy
because we were just talking about like
all of the bachelor fantasies right now
and i'm sending her videos going wendy
you're not going to believe what's
happening right now
[Music]